we've already won not entirely
but we talked about this already honey you
had an oatmeal crunch bar like two minutes ago
when we get to the island i'll buy
you a big fat juicy cheeseburger
and some soft serve ice cream if you're good
what's wrong uncle chris i'm not i'm not sure
so you're the new keeper nice katara i
need you to run as far away as you can
cathara is that what you told them your name was
it's very sneaky do you remember your real name
think hard it'll come to you really
and you remember who i am
you have to think very hard because it's been
a long long time since we last saw each other
papa
nothing makes my heart melt
more than hearing that word
sorry keeper but i think we'll be on our way now
i'm not letting her go i'm not asking i've been
marked by your bloodline you can't touch me
now what do you say we go
find your brother and sister
there's so many things that we have to catch up on
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my marvel hellstrom ending video for the end
credits scene i'll explain all the big ghost rider
easter eggs and what's going on with this show
and the new marvel shows because in the time that
they made this show in the time that it's been
released marvel television shows have changed
a lot if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're going to
be getting avengers one division episodes later
this year of course i'll be doing videos for
everything we'll do a new amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and let
me know what you want them to do with Ghost Rider
during marvel phase 4 i know everyone wants to
see him show up on the moon night series or show
up in the new blade movie but careful for spoilers
for everything that happened on the series if you
haven't seen it yet obviously we'll be talking
about the ending all the really big ghost rider
easter eggs starting with number 10 the hellstrom
character and his sister satana are able to team
up giving them a giant power boost and defeat the
group known as the blood who have been possessed
by demons themselves the hellstrom character
debuted in the ghost rider comics for most of his
lifespan in marvel comics he's been a ghost rider
character they cross over all the times he's been
part of the midnight sons he was even supposed to
become the new sorcerer supreme so he's a really
powerful character but he is the son of the devil
at least that's the way he started out they've
kind of changed his origin story a little bit
through marvel comics and more recent comics in
the year that the show picks up at the beginning
of the season demon activity had gone off the
charts but it was a larger symptom of what was
going on in that ending scene with mitch paleggi
showing up i'll explain him in a second too
number nine the caretaker in the blood are also
Ghost Rider characters as you would expect pretty
much everybody on this show is a Ghost Rider
character the caretaker originally was created
to be the keeper of secrets of humanity in the
world of demons but he worked a lot with johnny
blaze in the dany catch ghost rider characters
the blood's job in the comics was actually to
keep johnny blaze and danny ketch from coming
together and realizing that they were brothers so
if you didn't know that if you're not a big Ghost
Rider comic book fan probably the two most popular
versions of Ghost Rider of all time are actually
related through their father so they're kind of
like half brothers number eight talking about more
doctor strange easter eggs their group was also
the first group to beget a human sorcerer supreme
on earth thousands of years ago in the mcu the
ancient one is not the first sorcerer supreme in
earth's history but she has been sorcerer supreme
for eons we'll actually be going back thousands
of years in mcu history to learn some of the
origins of the marvel cinematic universe itself
in the eternals movie but that's not coming till
november next year so it'll be a while before we
see a trailer for that the whole reason why they
wanted to keep danny ketch and johnny blaze from
coming together when they were both versions of
Ghost Rider is because if they came together in
united which of course they wound up doing they
get this giant stacking bonus to their powers and
become too powerful for demons or humans to defeat
also unexpected venom easter egg if you look at
the spirals here that show up during the series
this is actually the spiral that shows up on
null in the symbiotes that he controls that in and
of itself is actually an easter egg for the spiral
of carcosa which is something that the authors all
took from a bunch of different series including
true detective which itself is also based on
real life mythology number seven the actual
fiery weapon he's using here the old looking
knife that he extends to the fiery trident is his
trademark comic book weapon that you always see
him depicted with the way the show explains it is
that it's a mystical blade that used to belong to
his true father satanish and it's the only weapon
that's ever been able to leave a mark on him is
what causes the symbol his brand on his chest to
manifest only hellstrom his sister and presumably
their father maybe lilith too would be able to
wield it to its true potential normal people could
probably just use it like a regular knife like you
would stab someone with a knife but it would be
like using the infinity gauntlet or iron man's
nano infinity gauntlet like a regular piece of
armor without having the infinity stones they'd
still be amazing pieces of armor really strong
but they wouldn't have any of their true potential
the trident is just like him attaining a legendary
weapon that has huge stacking bonuses to his power
but number six the whole thing with his sister
satana who they just call anna on the show is
that during the course of season one for the most
part she isn't really aware of her true powers but
she and hellstrom have the exact same power so
anything you see him do she can also do as well
they don't really get into great details but
they do the ghost rider johnny blaze danny ketch
storyline thing where they come together and
they get the major stacking bonus to their
powers by combining their abilities had the show
actually gotten a season two they probably would
have explored this in the two of them teaming
up to stop more powerful demons and fearlords
from the marvel universe and of course their
father and his new as old bride don't worry
i'll explain that twist in a second the caretaker
is still the caretaker but after gabriella's baby
is born the baby is basically the vessel for the
risen lilith or lily however you want to think
about her lilith is the mother of demons that
you know from pretty much every supernatural tv
show or movie that's used her the lilith who was
the first wife of adam but then cast down to hell
number four the whole thing with hellstrom's
mother as you saw during the trailer is that
she's actually been possessed by a demon many of
the main characters at various points during the
season were being possessed and they were trying
to manipulate hellstrom and their team pushing
pieces around the board trying to bring about
lilith's rebirth through gabriella so for part
of the season their mother like you saw in the
trailer acting all crazy was eventually exercised
and then by the ending here seemingly back to
normal number three after lilith is born gabriella
turns on hellstrom who fathered the child
but because she started out as this really
devout church-based character she kind of goes
a little crazy driven mad by the experience of
child birthing a demon the last scene there is her
joining the blood group who are devoted to killing
demons hellstrom and his sister are kind of demons
so she hates them now putting them at odds and she
doesn't want anything to do with them or the child
other than probably getting rid of them eventually
number two talking about this final scene
here a lot of questions i know about this
lilith and her keeper protector however you
want to think about him are then confronted by
hellstrom's father played by mitch paleghi from
x-files a billion other things you've probably
seen him from something recently they never
officially referred to him by name on the show
but initially in the ghost rider comics hellstrom
was supposed to be the son of the devil later in
more recent marvel comics they started naming him
as satanish just one of the more powerful demons
marvel has a really complicated power structure
when it comes to the greater fearlords who rule
over their own dimensions but talking about
more doctor strange easter eggs hell is just
another dimension in the marvel universe just
like dormammu rules over the dark dimension and
mephisto rules over his own hellish dimension
his whole mission in his ending scene is just
to reunite with lilith who is supposed to become
his bride and together they'll conquer the earth
in the main marvel dimension she grew eight years
in the span of six months so by the time season
two had picked up in another year or so she would
have aged up to adulthood and regained all of her
former memories as lilith and they would have
together become the big bads of the series the
number one bringing it back around to the ghost
rider character originally Ghost Rider himself
was supposed to cross over during the series in a
much bigger way the robbie reyes ghost rider from
agents of shield the show was supposed to help
create this pocket Ghost Rider universe that
they were going to use for a big team up series
called adventure interfere that was going to be
their new version of the marvel netflix defenders
team up with daredevil luke cage iron fist jessica
jones all crossing over in a big team-up series
they were going to do a supernatural Ghost Rider
based version of that they were also going to make
a separate ghost rider tv show with the robbie
reyes version from agents of shield but right
as they were getting ready to roll cameras on
that just a little while ago disney completely
reorganized the way marvel makes all of its tv
shows fired all the tv people including jeff loeb
and gave control of all future tv development to
kevin feige in the marvel studios people that
make the movies so all the new marvel shows are
coming from kevin feige in disney plus Wandavision
will be the first true version of that is a legit
avengers tv show that crosses over with the movies
all the movie actors are playing their characters
it's like falcon and winter soldier like the loki
tv series with tom hiddleston all the other ones
they've announced recently what'll probably
wind up happening now with the ghost rider
character particularly i know i always get a lot
of questions about that is that he'll show up in
future midnight sons style crossovers that they
do through the disney plus series like moon night
in the new blade movie the next big thing that's
happening is the mandalorian season 2 episodes are
starting next week i'll be doing videos for all
the episodes so make sure you have alerts enabled
for my channel so you don't miss anything let
me know if you spotted any other big Ghost Rider
easter eggs during the series if i didn't mention
them during this video but while you wait for
everything click here for that brand new marvel
shang chi first look teaser and click here for the
new mandalorian season 2 trailer thank you so much
for watching everyone stay safe this is the way!